yeah well mom Disney movie what's your
name but you want to be Vivian my name
is Vivian I would describe her as very
animated and and she's she's she's a
good-hearted person she's loved
misguided but she's she's a good girl I
like her I came in when they have Julia
Roberts in line and you didn't know
Julia Roberts but Julia Roberts I think
isn't going to be a big big movie star
for 9 G's oh honey no what's happened
I've got a runner in my pantyhose
I'm not wearing pantyhose
she's prostitute you know essentially
she um I think it's actually and to kind
of oversimplify it but in in a nice way
there to kind of lost souls who find
each other and then find themselves
through each other you know and so it's
kind of a coming together it's very nice
it's a big theme of somebody changing
another person in this case they change
each other in a fairy tale of it it's
the very surface stuff it's kind of the
changing clothes and changing
surroundings and stuff and that's the
kind of like wow the imagery but it's
the inside stuff the real stuff that's
very true to life I'm a safety girl I
talked to a lot of girls girls and it
was it was fascinating actually hear
their stories and to see the way they
looked in the way they dressed it wasn't
like you kind of imagined a real kind of
tardy and they look like just a girl
that you would know from school or
something and they were all very very
kind
very insightful I first you people
surprised me yeah well you're lucky most
I'm shocked the hell out of me
we have Julia we are additionally screen
tested people and nobody worked as well
as they do Richard I feel like when I
feel good about my work he'll support
that and he's very very complimentary
when the work is solid and if I'm lost I
don't feel I felt he'd go and say I'm
feeling really lost and he would kind of
help me find a way to get around where I
had to go
it's he makes it a very easy working
atmosphere Victor one of the point of
love making scenes we did that was just
terrific and I went to so well a
wonderful scene they both looked at me
and said why aren't you glad we get
along what a brat do people didn't get
along Gary you would have a mess
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I used to shop here for Christmas and it
was a place which connotates I think to
the American public with fancy stores
and for a street girl from the boulevard
to come here it was a big deal and we
wanted something that was a good
intimidated and where she was a bit
intimidated what are your plans while
you're in town I'm gonna have dinner but
don't sit there here I have attempted to
go shopping earlier and was not very
successful in getting the women in the
store to be very receptive to me I don't
think we have anything for you you're
obviously in the wrong place please
leave I am directed here by a man who
works at the hotel
Hector sends me here to talk to this
woman who he calls and sets the whole
thing up so I come here and now she's
going to help me find something to wear
to dinner
[Music]
you work on Commission right yes big
mistake big cute
[Music]